There’s a lot of planning that goes in to
making a movie.
It relies upon cooperation between dozens
of different departments, which can mean hundreds
of people working together.
And despite having a daily call sheet that
tells everyone where they need to be and when
they need to be there, productions can still
go off the rails.
So when tension is high, it can be nice to
have a team of funny people around to lighten
the mood.
And for a comedian, the best time to crack
a joke is when everything’s going wrong.
Thankfully, these ten productions had some
sneaky jokesters on hand who were waiting
to pounce at the right moment.
Before we start, can you guess the movie from
these emojis?
Stay tuned for the answer, and for some fun
trivia questions along the way.
If you like what you see, go have a look at
our channel.
And once you’re there, you can even sign
up for notifications so that when we post
new stuff, you’ll be the first to know.
Here are 10 Bloopers Comedy Actors Did On
Purpose!
Bridesmaids
When Paul Feig’s Bridesmaids was unleashed
upon the world, many people described it as
“The Hangover, but with chicks”.
And while we can sort of understand where
that comparison comes from, it couldn’t
be less accurate.
Written by Annie Mumolo and Kristen Wiig,
the movie craps all over the notion that women
must be ladies.
Like, literally craps on it.
So if you watched the scene and thought to
yourself “nobody would write this”, you're
kind of right.
The sequence wasn’t in the original draft
of the movie, but what else would you expect
from an entire team of improv heavy-hitters?
Shaun of the Dead
Have you ever heard of the Cornetto Trilogy?
How about the Blood and Ice Cream Trilogy?
Well, you might not recognize them by that
name, but we guarantee you’re familiar with
the movies it contains: The World’s End,
Hot Fuzz, and our personal favorite, Shaun
of the Dead.
Simon Pegg and Nick Frost are talented on
their own, but two heads are better than one
and these performers are made for each other.
Under the loose direction of Edgar Wright,
Frost and Pegg ad-libbed a lot of their dialogue
and cracked each other (and the crew) up throughout
the shoot.
The blood may have been fake, but the laughter
wasn’t.
Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Man’s Chest
Johnny Depp likes to really get into the character
he’s playing.
And if other people think he’s weird because
of it, well, that’s their problem.
Captain Jack Sparrow is one of his most popular
roles, and the actor held nothing back.
And while filming Pirates of the Caribbean:
Dead Man’s Chest, he kept everyone on their
toes.
During a scene where Depp dances around with
a jar of dirt containing the heart of Davey
Jones, take a look at the other people in
the scene.
The shock and confusion on their faces is
genuine, since the actor only told director
Gore Verbinski that he wanted to improvise
the ending, but didn’t say how.
Tommy Boy
Before there were amazing comedy duos like
Poehler and Fey, Key and Peele, and Stiller
and Wilson, there was Chris Farley and David
Spade.
The two old friends and SNL alumni often shared
the screen thanks to their undeniable chemistry.
And while some of their work was panned by
critics, fans gobbled it up.
Perhaps their best collaboration comes in
the form of Tommy Boy, a 1995 comedy goldmine.
By that point, the two actors had spent so
much time together that they had their own
little offscreen rituals — including ‘fat
guy in a little coat’.
Apparently, that was a routine Farley would
do whenever Spade was feeling down, and they
decided to throw it in to their performance.
There’s no telling how many jackets they
went through to get the proper take, but it
was definitely worth it.
Fast and Furious 6
If you were to just quickly glance at Dwayne
‘The Rock’ Johnson, your first instinct
might be to poop your pants.
He’s a hulking behemoth who could probably
throw a car the length of a football field.
So he’s probably someone you don’t want
to mess with.
In addition to being physically imposing,
the actor has a masters in trash talk from
WWE university.
So not only could he tear us apart with his
muscles, but he could hurt our feelings while
he does it.
Audiences got a peek at Johnson’s quick
tongue during a scene from the sixth installment
in the Fast and Furious franchise, with a
quip that was so good even Ludacris did a
spit take.
Dumb and Dumber
By this point, audiences are well-versed in
Jim Carrey’s comedic stylings.
The actor got his start performing at Yuk-Yuks
and The Comedy Store, so he’s comfortable
in front of an audience AND he can handle
hecklers.
But his talents don't stop there, he also
has a lovely singing voice.
To us, it sounds like the most annoying noise
in the world, but other improvisers hear comedic
gold.
Carrey might have been sitting on that gag
for a while, but it was a surprise to everyone
else on screen, and their reactions are genuine.
Even though he’s been working steadily since,
we bet the actor still has some tricks up
his sleeve.
The Wolf of Wall Street
Martin Scorsese is a cinematic genius, but
even he’s humble enough to get out of the
way and let his actors do their thing.
Especially when those actors are Leonardo
DiCaprio and Matthew McConaughey.
Between takes, DiCaprio saw McConaughey doing
an odd-looking vocal warmup where he hummed
and beat his chest at the same time.
The two performers schemed about including
the bit in the scene they were about to shoot.
And Scorsese is obviously great at recognizing
genius when he sees it, because even though
it wasn’t in the script, the gag thumped
its way into the final cut.
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
Willy Wonka is an eccentric dude.
In case you don’t know, the candy baron
stows himself away in his crazy candy factory,
and his daily social interactions are limited
to a gaggle of surly Oompa Loompas singing
mean songs.
When the golden ticket winners arrive for
their grand tour of the chocolate factory,
the gates open and Mr. Wonka greets them in
a way that only he could.
The somersault was a surprise to everyone
except for the man doing it, comedy legend
Gene Wilder.
He figured that an under-socialized character
would probably give an unconventional greeting.
And honestly, it’s perfect.
The Other Guys
When you’re working alongside someone as
hilarious as Will Ferrell, it can be hard
to keep your composure.
The actor is famous for his improvisational
skills, and when he’s riffing off the top
of his head, his co-stars do their best to
keep up.
So while the constant giggling creates a light
mood on set, it also results in a lot of takes
for the cutting room floor.
While filming a dinner scene, neither Ferrell,
nor his co-stars Eva Mendes and Mark Wahlberg
could hold back their laughter.
Every take resulted in a different response
from Ferrell, and each one was funnier than
the last.
Anchorman
When a director trusts their cast with the
material they’re given, they’re usually
okay with letting them mix it up a bit on
set.
And when the casting is as brilliant as it
was for 2004’s Anchorman, you’d have to
be a crazy person to assume that the comedians
would follow the script one hundred percent
of the time.
Thankfully for the audience, director Adam
McKay understands that the best things come
when you’re not expecting them.
A huge percentage of the movie’s final dialogue
was the result of improvisation.
And when your cast consists of Will Ferrell,
Steve Carrell, and Paul Rudd, it’s best
to just step out of the way and let them do
their thing.
What do you think?
Did we skip over any of your favorite intentional
bloopers from comedic actors?
We want to hear from you, so join the discussion
in the comments below.
And if you want to become a member of the
Screen Rant notification squad, subscribe
to our channel and sign up for updates.
It’s that easy.
Thanks for watching.